foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor hi friends would you like to
hear an amazing fact the largest
aircraft that ever flew was the Antonov
225 Maria means dream in Ukrainian the
aircraft was a modern engineering Marvel
featuring six massive turbofan engines
each as big as a cement mixer with an
overall size it stretched as far as a
football field from nose to tail and
wingtip to wingtip the an225 could carry
500 000 pounds of cargo that's twice as
much as a Boeing 747 freighter it was
designed and built in Ukraine throughout
the 1980s to transport the Soviet space
shuttle and it took its Maiden flight on
December 21 1988.
because it had a maximum takeoff weight
of up to 1.32 million pounds the an225
had 32 Landing Wheels with 20 of them
that were steerable
the monster aircraft made its
International debut in Style by landing
at the 1989 Parish Air Show with a
Russian space shuttle on its back
sadly only one an-225 was made and it
was destroyed by the Russian missiles in
February 2022
anyone who ever saw this Behemoth fly
will never forget the sensation of
wonder that something so heavy and
massive could travel gracefully through
the air you know Pastor Ross the Bible
speaks of an even larger transport that
will someday go through the skies that's
right Pastor Doug and no need for you
know Toba prop uh engines to move this
object through the sky but the Bible
does speak of a city that's going to be
coming from Heaven to Earth and of
course that City's cold the New
Jerusalem yeah and you can read about
that if you look in Revelation 21 verse
2 and 3 it says then I John saw the holy
city New Jerusalem coming down out of
Heaven from God prepared as a bride
adorned for her husband
and I Heard a Voice from Heaven saying
behold the Tabernacle of God is with men
and he will dwell with them and they
will be his people and God himself will
be with them and be their God
you know just uh it's difficult
sometimes for people to imagine
a City floating through the sky well
it's not as difficult maybe as it used
to be because we've got a space station
up there in the sky right now and if man
can do it then why would we think God
couldn't do it
so uh it is real God has a real City in
space that is going to come down out of
Heaven to the Earth and he wants you in
the city we have a special lesson that
talks about heaven in this colossal City
that's right and the study guide is
actually called a colossal City in space
that is a free offer to anyone who is
watching or listening to receive it just
call the number
800-835-6747 you can ask for offer
number 115 or you just dialed pound 250
on your phone and say Bible answers live
and then ask for the study guide is
called a colossal City in space we'll be
happy to send it to anyone here in uh
listening in North America the U.S and
Canada and if you're outside of North
America you can just go to our website
just
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
read the study guide right there for
free as well well as Mission pass today
this is Bible answers Lives who want to
welcome all of those who are joining us
across the country and around the world
and for those who are tuning in on the
internet and we want to welcome you as
well on the various television networks
you know before we get to the Bible
questions it's always important for us
to begin with prayer because we're
talking about God's book and if you're
going to understand God's book correctly
we want the Holy Spirit to be with us so
let's do that dear father we thank you
for your word we thank you for the
opportunity that we have to be able to
study and learn and we do ask your
blessing send the spirit that inspired
the book at the beginning to be with us
Lord and be with those who are listening
wherever they might be in Jesus name
amen amen all right we're ready to go to
the phone lines our first caller for
this evening is Elijah listening in
Washington Elijah welcome to Bible
answers live hello pastors thank you
guys for taking my call well thanks for
calling well our question was uh during
Jesus's Ministry on Earth here
um did he remember
his position in heaven and creating the
worlds and walking in the garden with
Adam and Eve and all those things that's
that that was my question and if he did
um or if he didn't is there a reason why
which I'm sure there is a reason why but
well that's a good question let's talk
about that for a minute so I think you
would agree Elijah that when when Jesus
was born as a baby
and he looked up at his mother and his
father he did not have all of the
knowledge of life and his pre-incarnate
existence in his mind or he would have
come forth into the world speaking he
had to learn to speak that means he
didn't know everything he probably had
to learn to walk like a normal child and
it it seems that as he needed to know
something his father in Heaven would
reveal it to him now did he know
something of his pre-existence yes
because he told the religious leaders
before Abraham was I am
so he knew something
and he says you know Abraham long to see
my day and he saw it
so I think that Jesus understood
something I'm not sure that at the time
he was living on the earth and walking
around that he had all the knowledge of
the creation and everything through
eternity in his mind but I don't know I
mean it just doesn't say you know just
add to that pass a day one time the
disciples asked Jesus they said when is
he coming back and Jesus said no man
knows the day or the hour only the
Father in heaven right so at that point
the specifics hadn't been revealed to
Christ yeah obviously now he does he's
with the father so there were some
things like you mentioned that they were
revealed to Christ as needed by the Holy
Spirit yeah
so yeah hopefully that helps Elijah good
question all right we've got Edward
listening in Arizona Edward welcome to
the program
hey how you doing pastors doing
wonderful thank you for calling thank
you for accepting my call if your
schizoaffective
do you have to overcome the
schizoaffective disorder
for your place in the kingdom of God and
if so how do you overcome it
well the Lord meets us where we're at
and uh you know I'm not saying that
medical conditions can be overcome
because of course Jesus can heal a
physical mental psychological illnesses
but that doesn't mean that a person that
may be struggling with these things will
always be healed and it doesn't mean
that something you know some medical
condition you're born with is going to
keep you from the kingdom I think God
expects us to surrender to him to trust
him we're saved by faith and to walk in
the light as we have it and uh
um any thoughts on that absolutely you
know as we come to Christ we can give
ourselves completely to him and say Lord
you know give me the strength to change
those things I can change and then give
me the the courage and the faith to
accept those things that I can't and
place it in your hand and believe that
you will work things out yeah so it's a
Cooperative relationship we're trusting
in God to do the work that only he can
do but we are surrendering ourselves to
him
yeah does that make sense uh Gary I'm
sorry Edward
oh yeah that does make sense okay well
you just keep trusting Jesus and ask him
to help you grow in Grace and victory
and you know always pray that uh he can
heal you because I never underestimate
God's ability to heal and to transform
that's the new birth
all right next holiday we have is Gary
listening in Illinois Gary welcome to
Bible answers live
in the church it's often said like God
protected Israel during the plagues will
be protected but I see in Matthew 24
verse 13 He Who endures to the end will
be saved it implies that we're suffering
because we're enduring and then again in
verse 22 but for the elect's sake these
days will be shortened and again it
flies that we're suffering and I think
it's already happening in Illinois we
got tornadoes two and three miles wide
travel for hundreds of miles so my
question is is God protecting us or or
what's going on
well it's a mix and let me use a Bible
example the children of Israel who went
through the ten plagues in Egypt God
protected them through the last seven
plagues but they also experienced the
same Calamity as the Egyptians for
through the first three plagues so um in
the last days when the seven last
plagues fall God is going to protect his
people I don't think what you're seeing
now are the seven last plagues because
once the seven last plagues begin
probation is closed and no one's going
to be saved after that so do Christians
the righteous sometimes suffer along
with the wicked yeah that that's always
been the case and God does Love and also
watches over his people but you know in
times of trial Believers often testify
by their faith through trial not because
he saves us from every trial and we grow
patience through trial
all right thank you Gary we've got
Judith listening in Nevada Judith
welcome to the program
can you hear me yes
yes okay wonderful thank you for taking
my call my question is uh didn't Jesus
uh come to the world the true course of
Calvary not just to
bring uh back his Perfect Circle of Love
and his Perfection home to Earth the
planet Earth but also he did it because
to restore the same circle of his love
and Shalom to the whole universe because
in assassinating his character by
Lucifer the Holy Angels did not
understand
can you please explain furthermore in
that perspective thank you yeah
so yes Jesus one of the things that
Christ did by his death is to
um restore a better image of the
character of God that's why Jesus said
if you've seen me you've seen the father
he said he came to reveal the father
among other things he also came as our
sacrifice and he also is restoring peace
not only to the planet it says then he's
going to make a new Heaven and a new
Earth all things that were made were
made by Jesus meaning he made the first
Heaven and Earth and uh then after the
wicked are judged he creates a new
Heaven and a new Earth and so there'll
be a total restoration and Satan and his
angels and all the wicked are going to
be destroyed with an everlasting fire
meaning they're burned up forever in the
universe has no more pain sorrow all
things are made new so it's a Total
Restoration of his original plan but
it's actually an upgrade you know the
Bible also tells us that when that time
comes when the Judgment has been taking
place and everybody sees the truth every
knee will bow and every tongue will
confess that Jesus Christ is Lord
there's no exceptions to that role so
that'll include both the Angels even the
Devil Himself will acknowledge that God
is fair and just in what he has done now
that doesn't mean it's genuine
conversion or repentance but there is an
acknowledgment of God's character yes
and that'll be manifest right at the end
of time
thank you appreciate that Judith all
right we've got Brad listening in
California Brad welcome to Bible answers
live my question pertains to Psalms 137
verse 1. and uh
it's kind of a two-part question I was
wondering I was always under the
impression that when David uh went to
his grave that uh he passed his Blessing
on to Solomon and he he thought that the
throne would be established in his
bloodline forever yet in Psalms 137 1
he's writing the song that the
Israelites sang
when they were taken captive in Babylon
and I was wanting I can't I'm trying to
wrap my head around that did he know
that Israel would eventually be taken
captive and
not tell his son yeah first of all
you know Jesus Brad didn't I'm sorry
David did not write all of the Psalms
David wrote about 70 maybe 71 of the
Psalms the later Psalms are written by
some of his musicians and others like
asaph and it talks about them you'll
notice that some of the Psalms will say
asalm of David and then some of them
like 137 it's talking about Babylon this
is a Psalm that was probably written
following the captivities and that's
your understanding Pastor Rossa there
because it's saying by the Rivers of
Babylon we wept this is after they had
been captured by Nebuchadnezzar it's one
of the later Psalms and so I don't know
if that helps with your question just to
know that David probably didn't write
this one
yeah I was always under the impression
that the whole book of Psalms was
written before Solomon took the throne I
used to think that all the Psalms were
written by David because so many of them
begin the psalm of David A Psalm of
David like Psalm 23
. but one Psalm is written by Moses I
think is it 90 or 91 is written by Moses
and many are by Solomon some are by
asaph but David wrote about 70 as near
as we can tell so
just about half
this is probably not one because it's
talking about the Babylonian captivity
that happened many generations now it is
true that that the son of David all the
sons of David
um that were was kept in the genealogy
and it mentions this in Matthew that
Jesus is a direct descendant of David
and Solomon and that he is the ultimate
son of David that would Reign forever
so the the line of the davidic promise
and the Covenant to David did not fail
some of the Kings did not Reign between
the Babylonian captivity in Christ
I think even zero bubble was a
descendant of David So briefly they had
a governor
but anyway hope that helps a little bit
thanks so much appreciate that Brad
all right next holder that we have is
Mark listening in Alaska Mark welcome to
Bible answers live
hey how's it
going to God
your interpretations and I really enjoy
listening to you guys sometimes because
it helps me with my interpretations well
thank you we appreciate it and glad we
could be of service and your question
tonight
yeah I had a question on 13th Matthew 13
44 and it talks about uh the treasure
the kingdom is like a treasure hidden in
a field and
maybe I'm wrong but it seems to me that
my understanding is the treasury ain't
hidden I think maybe I'm wrong but maybe
correct me I think that Jesus is saying
this treasure that is hidden is the
synagogue of Satan and they're in unity
in their hard workers this secular civil
government they're such hard workers
don't you think that maybe Jesus is
saying look at these people if the
Christians could only work as hard as
these people okay let's take a stab at
it now I want to read this for our
friends who are listening Mark
um a lot of folks are driving down the
road and they can't look it up
and this is in Matthew chapter 13 verse
44 again the Kingdom of Heaven is like a
treasure hidden in a field which a man
found in hid and for Joy over it he goes
and sells all that he has and buys the
field and it is true that the there are
people in the world that are very
um diligent workers but I think the the
picture in this Parable let me just back
you up in Bible times they did not have
Banks as we do today
and if people wanted to go shopping
they'd get their money they didn't
always keep it in the house because
maybe a little bit because people could
rob it and it was very common for people
to bury their Treasures somewhere on
their property
and it will often happen that someone
would die and someone else would find it
now right here in Northern California we
had someone up the road
they were out walking their dog and they
found
cans some like five five gallon old cans
filled with gold coins from the San
Francisco mint they're worth a fortune
millions of dollars they found on their
land
now this man he's leasing land and he's
out plowing the land and he uproots
someone's treasure and it says and he
hit it means he thought oh man I know
this chair this feels very valuable he
could just steal the treasure but he
doesn't he's honest he says I'm going to
buy the field then I own the treasure so
he covers it up and says he goes and he
buys the field he's willing to sell
everything to get the field this is
talking about really somebody who
discovers the good news of the gospel
and they realize its value and they sell
everything to get it now this Parable is
very much like the one who follows about
a merchant who finds a beautiful pearl
of great price and he sells everything
to get this one Pearl the point is Jesus
is saying they were willing to give all
for the treasure
and we need to be willing to he says if
you don't forsake all take up your cross
and follow me you're not worthy that
means we give God 100 of our heart he
said we need to love him more than our
father mother sister brother husband
wife we need to love him first and so
this is one of the many parables that
talks about it's worth everything to
follow Christ
all right thank you Mark we've got Anna
listening in Oregon Anna welcome to
Bible answers live
evening passers evening my point my my
question is uh about jewelry
and what the Bible says about it but in
particular wearing wearing a cross is
that is that a part of like idol worship
uh well I would say you know certainly
there can be a lot of people in heaven
that wore crosses but there's really no
command in the Bible that says to wear a
cross we're told to Bear the cross
and uh you know the cross was a it's an
instrument of torture so I don't know
that the anywhere in the Bible had ever
told us to make crosses and bow to them
and everything and I realized that you
know Paul says I'm determined to know
nothing among you but Jesus Christ and
him crucified and all glory in the cross
and that means the sacrifice of Christ
but sometimes we sort of make an idol
out of the icon of the Cross and we're
not really told to do that in the Bible
uh now that you know that could be
lumped together with the idea of jewelry
um and you know folks that have listened
to me for years know that I think that
uh there are commands in the Bible that
say and principles that say that
Christians should avoid wearing jewelry
and artificial ornamentation not only
because it's the cost and the display
but there are some scriptures like where
Peter says let the adorning not be the
outward adoring and think this is First
Peter chapter three don't let it be the
outward adorning the wearing of gold or
apparel pulses let it not be you know
gold and pearls and costly array let it
be modest and uh then in Isaiah talks
about the daughters of Babylon that go
around with you know swishing as they go
wearing and he talks about a number of
jewelry items earrings and so forth no
nose rings and
and I think Christians are best known by
Simplicity a few years ago a lot of
televangelists got into trouble with
various scandals and the world was
having fun making fun of the
televangelists and many of them were
Prosperity preachers that it was just a
lot of gaudy jewelry and makeup
and they were mocked because of their
appearance so I advocate that the Bible
teaches Christians ought to be modest
clean and neat modest it doesn't mean we
need to wear Rags but I think we ought
to avoid any kind of ornamentation and
again there's nowhere I know people
think wearing a cross is good luck well
that's idolatry you know
there's no good it's not a chicken bone
or something that a rabbit's foot
so uh yeah just letting people know
you're a Christian is the best thing now
I do have a book that actually talks
about this it's called jewelry how much
is too much
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone here in North America in the U.S
or in Canada the number to call for that
is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
called jewelry how much is too much you
cannot just dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live and
then you can also ask for the book that
way as well
if you have a Bible question our phone
line here in the studio is
800-463-7297 we got Philip listening in
Arkansas Phillip welcome to the program
hi good evening thanks for taking my
call yes thank you Revelation yeah I
have a question on Revelation 13 13-14
um do you guys think that the signs and
wonders and miracles part that of the uh
that the second beast performs and the
side of the first Beast has that started
to become fulfilled yet and if so do you
think AI plays any type of role with
technology in the end yeah it's a
fascinating question I've been thinking
a lot about AI this weekend I'll even
make a public confession that I I tried
to manufacture my first AI picture well
I did I didn't do it but I I use one of
the online programs to see if it would
produce a picture of angels flying
through heaven and it did it was pretty
kind of rough but it did I and I think
boy it's a scary technology do I think
that's the signs and wonders no uh the
second beast is alive and well today
I don't think that it's using the signs
and wonders it's going to use to
manipulate the the first beasts and the
rest of the world yet because the the
spiritual issues haven't really matured
I don't know if you have any thoughts on
that Pastor Ross yeah when it talks
about it one of the signs specifically
mentioned is it talks about fire coming
down from heaven that the second beast
will do and we know from the Bible Fire
coming down from heaven is often
associated with the spirit of God or a
counterfeit of the spirit of God it can
be a blessing or it could be a judgment
so what we find in the last days is
there's this religious movement and it
appears as though God's blessing is on
it there's the fire is coming out from
Heaven there's much emphasis on the Holy
Spirit and miracles and wonders
and it's not the spirit of God it's a
counterfeit spirit that is leading
people astray in the last days and that
power working with the political power
described to the second piece of
Revelation 13 sets things up at the end
yeah
yeah we remember in the story of Elijah
that the great proof that God was with
Elijah is that fire came down from
heaven so what's the world going to
think when all of a sudden the great
proof that Elijah uses now being used by
the counterfeit
it's going to be very deceptive well
hope that helps a little thanks so much
we got two minutes can we do one more
before our break we've got Lee listening
in Texas Lee walk to the program
yes um I was calling because I was
supposed to be in my re-baptize on
Easter but then but I've been baptized
them four times in my life and being
baptized again on Easter was would have
been my fifth time my past the pastor
that was going into it said it's not
necessary being that I've been baptized
so many times do I still need to be
re-baptized again or or is it not
necessary well let me tell you there's
three principal reasons a person might
be re-baptized one would be if they've
never been baptized biblically by
immersion some people are baptized as
babies and and they just didn't know
what was going on or they've been
sprinkled and the Bible is very clear we
should be immersed in the water that's
what the word baptize means another
reason to be re-baptized would be
if you've come into just a whole new
understanding of what the truth is and
an example of that would be Acts 19
where it says these 12 you read the
first few verses these 12 Ephesian
believers they had heard about John the
Baptist they got baptized by immersion
but they had not heard about Jesus they
left town before they heard about that
and the outpouring of the spirit Paul
preached him all this new truth they'd
missed and they said we want to get
baptized again and they were and they
were filled with the Holy Spirit third
reason to be re-baptized would be is
you've kind of divorced yourself from
the Lord
um it doesn't mean you know you so
you're baptized and then you you sin and
you make a mistake you got to run and
get baptized again well we'd all be
getting baptized every week if that was
the case so but if a person is totally
they've stopped going to church they've
backslidden and um it's not that they
get discouraged for a week or two but
the tenor of their life they sort of
divorce themselves from the church and
the Lord
when they return it would probably be
appropriate to be re-baptized but not in
every case and it there's variables now
how often should a person be re-baptized
well
it's like marriage you know you if a
person says I've been married 10 times
well you think there's a problem there
um it's a sacred ordinance and you don't
want to be doing it carelessly or
frequently so
um it should be done with great care and
that Covenant should be protected
sometimes a person could just go through
the communion service and that will
serve as like a mini baptism
and that gives them gives all of us a
new beginning
so I hope that helps a little bit and we
do have a book on baptism is it
necessarily you can get a free copy just
call and ask for that call amazing facts
and we'll be happy to send it to anyone
in North America who calls and asks all
right friends don't go away we're going
to take our mid-time break coming back
with more Bible questions in a moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
go into all the world and preach the
gospel to Every Creature through radio
television print Evangelistic events and
the internet amazing facts International
is heeding the call of Jesus to go into
all the world millions of individuals
and over 150 countries have been blessed
by the word of God amazing facts have
spawned new spheres of influence in
India Africa China and Indonesia with
each new country come hundreds of
translated booklets study guides and
video presentations produced in each
region for the people of that region
armed with these precious truths gospel
workers are empowered to spread bright
rays of light on every path they travel
please visit
[Music]
reachtheworld.amazingfacts.org to learn
more about amazing facts International
and how you can participate in this
exciting soul-winning Ministry that
website again is reach the
world.amazingbacks.org thank you for
your support
the U.S government is drowning in debt
to the tune of 22 trillion dollars but
before you wag your finger at the
government spending the Federal Reserve
says the average American household
carries over a hundred and thirty seven
thousand dollars in debt while it was
never God's plan that we live with the
burden of death Proverbs 22 7 warns us
the rich rules over the poor and the
borrower is servant to the lender living
with debt is a stressful bird that
actually hurts your relationship with
God in my new pocketbook deliverance
from debt I outline the Bible principles
on how to properly manage your money
with some practical suggestions and how
you can get out and stay out of debt if
you or someone you love is drowning in
debt order a copy of Deliverance from
debt today it can be a lifesaver to keep
you from going under it please call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back to listening friends to
Bible answers live and we're here to do
our best to answer any Bible question
you might have about the word of God or
living the Christian Life we've got our
Bibles at our fingertips and you can
simply call it's a free phone call and
that number is
800-463-7297 and that's 800 God says
we're streaming also on Facebook and
YouTube We're on aftv and replayed on
Hope Channel and a number of other
networks my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross and we got a number of
callers waiting with their Bible
question we're going to go to
um Joan in Australia Joan welcome to the
program hello
hi doing good thanks for calling my
question comes
when it comes to name and and with the
Prophet Elijah Elisha and the King Hayes
eye and I just want to
um if you could help me paint the
picture
um uh went
um accepted uh by lie a payment
I went back and and the prophet said
did my heart not go with you
um is it now that we accept payments and
then profit Elijah says
um
Captain neyman's leprosy will now be
with you and he walked out as white as
snow
so as the story goes on in the in the
Bible with Elisha it also continues with
the hazai so I was just thinking so does
he continue working with the prophet
at what a smart
with Leprosy yeah no I think the next
time you see gehezai he may be well
there's two possible times there are
four lepers in uh Second Kings chapter
six all right actually they're in second
Kings chapter seven during a famine and
then Josephus is one of those four
lepers that uh said we're not doing what
is right this is a day of good news may
have been his eye
um later you see gehazai he's talking to
the king and telling the king about the
Miracles
of Elisha and a person might say well
he's got leprosy what's he doing talking
to the king well there's a few different
possibilities one is that he was later
healed and forgiven uh doesn't say that
in the Bible the other is even people
with a leprosy could communicate but
they had to keep a certain distance and
so maybe he was talking to the king it
was some distance between them because
he was unclean that's a difficult
scenario to imagine so
um you know we can only speculate
because I does appear later in the story
after he gets leprosy he's talking to
the king and telling about the Miracles
of Elisha so he may have been healed
it's hard to say
yeah and the other one last story was
the the lady that um didn't have a child
yeah the shunome woman
yes yeah and the story of the shunamite
not all the stories of Elisha's Miracles
are in chronological order the emphasis
is that Elisha has doubled the Holy
Spirit of Elijah and then it begins to
recount examples of his miracles I'm not
sure that they're all written in
chronological order so the shunamite I
think happened before the story of
Naaman
okay thank you thanks great questions
all right next holiday we have is
Abigail in Florida Abigail welcome to
the program
hey pastors how are you guys we're doing
much better than we deserve
awesome my question is um in Matthew 27
52 53
um who were the Saints they were
referring to were they people and did
they ascend into heaven or where did
they go okay good question
um in Matthew 27 it talks about that
when Christ died on the cross after he
cried out Lord you know into your hands
I commend my spirit it is finished
there's a great earthquake
and in connection with that earthquake
it's as many of the graves not all it's
not a universal uh Resurrection but many
and not all the graves around Jerusalem
but some of the graves of saints save
people who were resting in their graves
around Jerusalem were opened and then
after when Christ came out of his grave
Sunday morning some of them arose and
appeared to people in Jerusalem briefly
probably because it's not even mentioned
in John or Mark or Luke
but there were people who saw some of
the resurrected saints that evidently
they ascended to heaven with Christ when
he ascended after he'd spoken with Mary
and who were they doesn't name them
there are some people who were Believers
in God Faithful buried somewhere in the
area around Jerusalem
and probably not John the Baptist
because I think he was buried down by
the Jordan somewhere uh it you know
could have been people like Isaiah we
don't know it doesn't say their names
but how many we don't know but there is
a first fruits that I think you've got a
verse in Ephesians yeah there is
Ephesians chapter 4 verse 8 actually
talks about a group that ascended with
Jesus and here you have poll quoting the
Old Testament he says for when he
ascended on a high he laid captivity
captive and gave gifts unto men
and he's actually quoting it from Psalm
68 but it's referring to those who are
held captive by death or by the grave
they were resurrected and they ascended
with Jesus when he ascended to heaven
yep so hope that helps a little bit
Abigail and uh yep the we do have a
study guide that talks about the dead
and it's in the resurrection it says are
the Dead really dead and if you're
interested we can send you a free copy
of that the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 and again just ask for the
study guide is called are the dead
rarely Dead next holiday we have is Inga
listening in Canada welcome to the
program
hello Pastor hi
hi my question is um is there going to
be technology in heaven
well uh when you say technology of
course you know God is the author of all
true science and so there will there be
scientific wonders I would think of
course
um will we have smartphones
probably not because I'm thinking that a
lot of things that the smartphones are
doing now will be able to do in
Supernatural ways when we get to heaven
we won't need a GPS I think the holy
spirit's going to tell us where we are
we'd get lost pretty quick in the
universe
had some kind of divine GPS but we'll be
you know we'll be probably doing all
kinds of research into the Beauties and
wonders of God and I I says we're going
to plant Vineyards and eat the fruit and
build houses so we're doing constructive
things is it plausible that as history
goes by we'll be making things yeah I
believe so
all right thank you next goal of their
behalf is Jerry listening in Oregon
Jerry welcome to Bible answers live
uh good evening pastors Ross and uh
Bachelor I'm reading John 5 24 which
says verily truly I tell you whoever
hears my word and believe him who sent
me has eternal life and will not be
judged but has crossed over from Death
To Life
but
the when I look at Matthew 12 36 it says
that
everyone will have to give an account of
Every Idle Word
and then Revelation 20 12 says that the
books are open and the dead are judged
according to what they have done so my
question is are the Believers judged or
not judged all right let me there's one
more you've read some good verses there
uh you can look well I might give you
two more Romans 14 10 Paul says in the
last part of that for we will all stand
he's talking to the church we will all
stand before the Judgment seat of Christ
and then if you look in second
Corinthians 5 10 it says for we must all
appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ that each one may receive the
things done in the body so with that in
mind what does it mean there in the
Gospel of John where it says we we've
passed from judgment I think that he's
basically saying that because of the
blood of Christ our sins are stricken
from the books so when they look in the
books it says forgiven but the books are
going to be examined and the only way
that our Deeds are not going to rise up
against us is if they are a confessed
repented of and under the blood of
Christ but there's still a judgment that
that reveals that now some judgment
takes place before Jesus comes because I
think it's obvious to everybody that if
Christ is Distributing rewards when he
comes
some investigation takes place before he
sometimes referred to as a pre-advent
judgment so the Judgment sort of happens
in three phases it tells us that we will
judge Angels Paul says during the
Millennium judgment is given to the
Saints and and there's we're looking at
the judgments of God of why some people
maybe aren't there and why some people
are there I can picture in the
resurrection that when Stephen sees the
Apostle Paul in heaven he's going to
think the Angels did something wrong
because the last time Stephen sees Paul
he was killing Christians now he's in
heaven so the Stephen will get to look
at the Judgment books and so we're sort
of looking at some of the judgments of
God and then there's a final great white
Throne judgment where all the debtor
resurrected and that's called an
executive judgment they're given their
penalty but again the books are open and
every knee and saved lost Devil's Angels
everybody is going to Bible for Christ
and say he is Lord
you know we have a couple of study
guides that talk about the Judgment
people want to learn more about that
um if you call and ask for the final
judgment it's one of the amazing facts
study guides we'll be happy to send that
to you you can also ask for the one
called right on time that sort of part
one and part two about the Judgment the
number to call for that is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
study guide called right on time and the
final judgment will tell you all about
what's happening in this heavenly
courtroom that's described in the Bible
so 800-835-6747
next caller that we have is Aaron
listening in New York Aaron welcome to
Bible answers live
good evening pastors good evening if a
stranger insults You by calling you a
derogatory word for no apparent reason
and immediately leaves you so that you
cannot ask them what happened is it okay
to do nothing about the insult and act
like it never happened or should you
give a prayer for forgiveness
boy that stranger well Jesus said
uh when people say all manner of evil
against you falsely for my namesake
rejoice
and the Bible then tells us to turn the
other cheek and pray for those who
spitefully use you and persecute you so
the answer on both counts According To
Jesus teaching is as far as possible try
and turn the other cheek now if I'm
standing on the corner and some lunatic
comes up and starts you know taking
swings at me I'll probably defend myself
but
um you know if someone insults you you
just turn the other cheek I I get
criticism
all the time some of it's deserve some
of it's just being mean and you know I
don't respond to retaliate because
you know that's what Jesus did that's
what I think he wants us to do when they
you look at the trial of Christ they
said all kinds of terrible things to him
and about him and he really didn't
defend himself and pilate was amazed
so um and then of course pray for Jesus
prayed for those crucifying him so
should we pray for people that uh
spitefully use us and persecute us yes
is it hard yes but that's where we're
developing Christian virtues thanks
Aaron appreciate that
next caller that we have is Carlos
listening in Florida Carlos welcome to
the program
good evening passage hi
Hebrews 4
verse 4 says uh for he spake in a
certain place of the seventh day on this
wise comma uh what what what what
certain place and I'm not understanding
this uh this term here where do you have
a king are you guys reading from King
James
yeah well I've got the new King James
here it's almost identical
so so it says for he spake in a certain
place of the seventh day on this wise on
this wise means in this way
yeah
he's quoting from the Old Testament in
Exodus 20 where it says God rested the
seventh day and he may also be quoting
from Genesis 2 2 because it says it in
both places
so so the play so the place he's
speaking from is the seventh day
well no it means that uh the that King
David he's quoting about he's talking
about King David in chapter four of
Hebrews and it says for he spoke in a
certain place we're actually talking
about for God spoke in a certain place
of the seventh day and God rested from
his work and he's talking about were in
Genesis 2 2. it says that um God rested
from his work in creating the world
what is a certain place it means in the
script A Place in the scripture and the
places yeah he's talking about he's
spoken he's quoting various verses like
if you look in verse 3 it says so I
swore in my wrath they will not enter my
rest here he's quoting from psalm 95.
uh so Hebrews he's going through
different places in the Old Testament I
think there are more quotes more Old
Testament quotes in Hebrews than any
other New Testament book
I think Matthew and Romans might be next
hey thank you Carlos I hope that helps a
little bit
next quarter that we have is Troy
listening in Massachusetts Troy welcome
to the program
good evening pastors I just want to
thank you guys for your faithfulness and
amazing facts have had a huge impact on
my family so I just want to thank you
guys praise God my question now it's
about Daniel and Ezra we know what the
70-week prophecy
um with Ezra chapter 7 is where it
starts the 70 week prophecy and I'm
reading Ezra now okay in Ezra chapter
four with the resistance of building the
Temple and
um
it says artix Xerxes had sent a
um a letter to to Cease the work that's
been going on in Jerusalem and it says
until the second year of the reign of
Darius king of prurges Ezra chapter 4
and verse 24. my question is
is this the same Arctic Xerxes that
comes forth in chapter seven because in
chapter six we have the issuing of the
decree of Darius
and then chapter one was from Cyrus I'm
just kind of confused if it's the same
art exerts you use in chapter four
that's in chapter seven yeah that makes
any sense I yeah good question I think
that it is different
um you know sometimes they had sons are
rulers there's actually more than one
Darius
that had the same name there's a Darius
during the time of Daniel and then years
later you get another Darius during the
time of Ezra and I could be wrong Pastor
Ross but I think the one in chapter
seven is the art of Xerxes who did the
decree that allowed them to go home and
the one who put up a blockade that you
find in chapter four I think it was a
different king during a different time
so I don't know if you uh
know more about that yeah I was just
going to mention a couple of other there
are three decrees that are particularly
significant to the Jews that allow them
to go back and restore and rebuild
Jerusalem and
um the first decree was by Cyrus the
second was by Darius in 519 and then
Auto Xerxes was in 457 BC so that's the
one that's really recorded for us in
Ezra is the decree that allowed the Jews
to go back not only rebuild the Temple
but actually the wall of the city and
that's the decree in 457 BC that starts
the 70 weeks or the 490 years so is
there another autosourxes that could be
but this is the one that the Bible
speaks of especially in Ezra it's been
the most significant in issuing that
decree yeah the decree is actually found
in chapter seven so I think he's
wondering is that artist Xerxes in
chapter four the same one in chapter
seven and I'm trying to go back in my
Persian history and remember I just
remember there were some of these kings
that had the same name but I know the
art of Xerxes in chapter seven that's
the Korea 457 mm-hmm so I'm gonna have
to go look that up again because I'm
second guessing what I said all right
that just goes to show you friends we
don't have all the answers but we'll
we'll research that Troy I want to make
sure I'm giving you the right answer
thank you thanks next Call of the behalf
is Nicole listening in Michigan Nicole
Welcome to the program
Hi how are you doing good thank you for
calling
good I have a question about Numbers
chapter 28 verse 7 it says that strong
drink was to be offered in the sanctuary
what is that strong drink because I'm
under the impression that the people of
God were not supposed to have anything
to do with alcoholic beverages and
especially not in the sanctuary so what
is the strong drink there yeah that
that's I think often misunderstood the
word strong there it could in some
places mean strong as an alcohol they
had another word for strong and it's the
word like concentrated now you've
probably had orange juice before that
was made from concentrate
um I'm guessing you've tasted what
orange juice from concentrate tastes
like before you add the water
and you could say that's really strong
the Jews used to actually dehydrate
their grape juice so they could
transport it and you know liquids are
very heavy they would dehydrate it make
it into a syrup and then they'd
reconstitute it that sometimes was
called strong drink the word strong
their meaning Intense or concentrated
it might not be alcoholic at all and it
matter of fact could be very sweet
almost a syrup but then you'd add water
again and it was just right this may
very well be what they're talking about
because I I don't think God approved
them using alcohol uh the two sons of
Aaron were burnt to death God rained
fire down on Heaven from them for
drinking alcohol before they went to the
sanctuary it would seem strange that he
would then endorse people
bringing all the alcohol into the
sanctuary and of course we do have
Leviticus actually Leviticus chapter 10
verse 9 says do not drink wine or
intoxicating drink when you or your sons
who are with you going to the Tabernacle
of meeting so part of the sacrifice that
was given would also be used to help
sustain the priesthood so the priesthood
clearly told that they were not to be
drinking alcohol when they were involved
in the same price so um it was a
concentrated sort of grape juice that
could be diluted with water yeah and if
you uh I've got a book called alcohol on
the Christian I think it references I
wrote it you know 15 years ago so I
don't even remember everything it's in
it but I think it references the um the
strong drink that you find in this
passage the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
called alcohol on the Christian we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks you can also dial pound 250 on your
smartphone as for Bible answers live and
then ask for the book the alcohol or
alcohol and the Christian next wallet
that we have is Mike listening in
Missouri Mike welcome to the program
well here let me get to it real quick uh
my question concerns Acts chapter 12
verse 4 of the King James version and
according to the Julian concordance the
word for Passover in that particular
passage is Easter now should this
question is based on hearsay I've never
been able to find this in writing but
this person told me that uh
um
that East I'm going to State it in the
question is Easter the correct name for
Passover when calculated by a Julian
calendar
uh no well
the word Easter is not the word in the
original when they're translating it
into uh English
because the time of the Passover is the
same time of year as the Catholics
that's celebrated and even the Orthodox
church or whether you call it Church of
England at the same time they celebrated
Easter not always the same day because
they would pick it differently the Jews
use the more of a lunar cycle
that um it's basically just saying that
Herod was going to execute Peter during
the Passover or after Passover was over
I think it's letting us know that's the
same time of year they were gonna they
did execute Jesus
so they use the word Easter there in the
King James but you'll find in most other
versions they translate that Passover
what the exact date was I think it would
be according to the Jewish calendar not
the Roman Calendar
because this is written by a Jew so it's
a lunar calendar the Jewish civil
calendar okay
he's just saying that Herod didn't
execute him right away because they're
waiting for the Passover to be over and
if you look at the same verse in the new
King James which is very close to the
King James it does use the word Passover
in place of Easter yeah so it sort of
corrects that a better a better word in
that case all right thank you next
holiday we have is Linda listening in
California Linda welcome to the program
thank you I'm confused about which are
the people
who will fight with the devil against
the New Jerusalem
who will be fighting against the devil
who's fighting with the devil what tells
us Gog and Magog the devil rallies Gog
and Magog and you find that in Exodus
chapter 20 and next to this 20 is sort
of quoting from Ezekiel 37 and 38 God
20. oh sorry Revel yeah Revelation thank
you very much uh in Revelation chapter
20. where did the people come from
because before the second coming the
Earth is uh I'm getting to that okay
gotcha yeah
they're they're resurrected it says the
rest of the dead and now we're in
Revelation chapter 20. the rest of the
Dead live and not again until the
thousand years are finished so the dead
in Christ rise first so all the
righteous are resurrected there's only
one group left who are the rest of the
Dead if all the righteous are
resurrected in the first resurrection it
says the dead in Christ rise first in
first Thessalonians who were the rest of
the Dead be Linda
you're lost that's right it's a wicked
it calls them Gog and Magog in
Revelation because the Revelation uses
symbolic names for almost everybody it
uses Balaam and uh in Napoleon and the
lamb and the lion and Jezebel and and it
uses Gog and Magog because in the Old
Testament those were enemies of God's
people from Antiquity Gog and then
you've got Magog means from The Matrix
of God or the children of Gog so it's
like Babylon and her daughters Gog and
Magog the wicked and the children of the
wicked are you've got the good it says
the woman and the seed of the woman so
you've got the good side and the
children of the woman you get the bad
side in the children of the wicked and
uh so it's in all who have ever lived
from every generation they are coming
against the people of God and the devil
is rallying them to assault the city of
God and I think you also find that in
the book of Zechariah Chapter 14. and
God delivers his people at the crucial
moment now I hope that helps a little
bit uh Linda we we thank your friends
just in case you did not know this the
amazing facts were on many different
venues right now we broadcast on TV on
radio through satellite and land-based
TV and radio stations the clocks aren't
all the same on these different networks
and because of the timing difference
between satellite and land-based
stations we say farewell first to our
satellite listeners and those are
listening on satellite radio we love you
nothing personal but we're going to sign
off with you but the rest of you don't
go away because then we come back and we
do our best to do rapid fire Bible
questions that you have emailed in so
stay tuned for that for the rest God
bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends welcome back to Bible
answers live and again as Pastor Doug
mentioned just on the other side of the
break we're going to take some of your
email questions so if you'd like to send
us an email question our email address
is balquestions at
amazingfacts.org and we'll try to answer
as many of these questions as we can in
the time allotted about two and a half
minutes past today first question we
have if Satan was cast to the Earth
where did he go during the flood
yeah I think people sometimes wonder if
the whole world is flooded and if the
devil was not in the ark then you know
they're looking at the Devil as though
he's got a physical body but the Bible
says we do not wrestle Ephesians chapter
six we do not wrestle against flesh and
blood I mean if we did I'd love to punch
the devil in the nose
of course I'm probably not stronger than
him physically but but he's a spirit
and he can sometimes manifest himself in
physical ways but ultimately he's a
spirit so I don't think he was worried
about drowning per se
he didn't need scuba gear or anything
but he probably saw the catastrophe of
the elements and feared for his own
existence when he saw what was happening
to humanity he saw the terrible judgment
that came on mankind he probably feared
but no he didn't didn't need to worry
about drowning okay we have Rachel
asking will the 144 000 know that they
are part of this group during the time
that they're on the earth or would not
be made known to them until Jesus's
Second Coming
well that's a good question and I'm not
sure I know the answer
um the 12 apostles knew that they were
the 12 that had been specifically chosen
uh will the 144 000 know that they're
you know
142 2003 uh no not necessarily I I think
that there's going to be a special
Spirit-filled group of Apostles you
might say in the last days doing a great
work but they may not know that they're
one of them all right next question that
we have can Fallen Angels still repent
and be saved or is the Plan of Salvation
only for human beings
well probation is open for humans now
there was probably a time when Angels
could have repented God gave them a
period of Grace and we don't know it may
have been thousands of years while this
debate went on in heaven but ultimately
their probation closed and the the
Angels know that they are now in
Everlasting chains of darkness and the
demons often said to Jesus we know who
you are have you come to torment us
before the time meaning judges so they
know they're the devil knows he has a
short time there's no turning back the
Fallen Angels have no redeemable
qualities left friends great questions
and we hope we can have more great
questions next week give us a call in
the meantime check out
amazingfacts.org and keep us on the air
God bless
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]